ohne Rollstuhl kannoxana Garda aus Halle
nicht mehr aus dem Haus sie ist 36 Jahre
alt direkt nach der zweiten Impfung
gegen Corona bekommt sie Herzrasen hat
einen schwächeranfall schließlich liegt
sie Monate nur im Bett kann nicht mal
allein auf die Toilette gehen
ich habe bestimmt Impfung meiner Lebens
verloren
ich bin noch jung eigentlich noch und ja
ich weiß es nicht ist das weite sich
entwickelt ich habe Pflegegrad 2
ich habe eine Rente beantragt ja
es klingt ja mit 36 und hinten sein das
ist unglaublich noch vor eineinhalb
Jahren war sie gesund und topfit
arbeitete als Physiotherapeutin
[Musik]
nach der Impfung bescheinigen ihr Ärzte
das fatig-syndrom eine schwere
chronische Krankheit und eine Störung
des Kreislaufsystems im Arztbrief heißt
es unerwünschte Wirkung bei der
Anwendung von kovit 19 Impfstoffen
Oxana Garda will deshalb den
Impfstoffhersteller biontech verklagen
auf 100000 € Schmerzensgeld
das bringt meine Gesundheit leider nicht
zurück aber
mindestens Gerechtigkeit und etwas Geld
auch wir haben schon über 1000 über
10.000 Euro abgegeben für alle Therapien
wir müssen alles selber aus eigener
Taschen bezahlen alles
sie hat sich ein Anwalt genommen der
vertritt insgesamt 850 Mandanten gegen
die Impfstoffe Hersteller
entscheidend wird sein ob es gelingt ein
direkten Zusammenhang zwischen der
Impfung und der Krankheit nachzuweisen
und insofern betreten wir Neuland und
müssen uns ebenfalls auch durch die
Instanzen durchkämpfen ich sehe auch
eine Gutachter Schlacht auf uns zukommen
mit gerichtlichen Gutachten
Obergutachten eben wegen der Kausalität
bei jontech hat im Dezember 2020 mit
kumia Nati den ersten Impfstoff gegen
Corona auf den Markt gebracht ein
Interview zu den klagen will das
Unternehmen nicht geben schriftlich
heißt es auf unsere Anfrage es gäbe
keine Anhaltspunkte die einen kausalen
Zusammenhang zwischen der Impfung mit
kummernathie und diesen gesundheitlichen
Beeinträchtigungen belegen
die Mainz hat in den vergangenen zwei
Jahren
19,7 Milliarden Euro Gewinn gemacht
aber haften für mögliche Impfschäden
muss das Unternehmen des Gründer
Ehepaars nicht
denn die EU hat 2020 noch bevor der
Impfstoff auf den Markt kam in diesem
geheimen Vertrag unter anderem mit
biontech-vereinbart dass die
Mitgliedstaaten also auch Deutschland
mögliche Schadensersatzzahlungen
anstelle der impfstoffproduzenten
übernehmen
und damit nicht genug das deutsche
Gesundheitsministerium hat für die
kovid-impfstoffe noch eine
Sonderregelung geschaffen
in dieser Verordnung vom 25 Mai 2020
werden Ausnahmen vom Arzneimittelgesetz
festgelegt demnach gilt die Haftung nur
bei grober Fahrlässigkeit oder Vorsatz
eine enorme Hürde ist ja so schon so
dass das Arzneimittelgesetz hohe Hürden
für Entschädigungen vorsieht aber das
übertrifft alles sonst sie da gewesene
und bedeutet für den Impfling das ist
für ihn noch schwieriger wird seine
Ansprüche durchzusetzen der Anwalt klagt
gegen die Bundesregierung hält die
Verordnung für rechtswidrig das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium bestreitet
das
wie schwierig es ist vom Staat Geld zu
bekommen merken Betroffene wenn es um
die Anerkennung von Impfschäden geht die
Voraussetzung für Versorgungsansprüche
frontal hat alle Bundesländer angefragt
bisher sind bei den Versorgungsämtern
7.984 Anträge eingegangen
2490 wurden abgelehnt in 325 Fällen
wurde ein Impfschaden anerkannt die
meisten Anträge werden noch bearbeitet
der Antrag der 18-Jährigen Eileen wurde
abgelehnt die Schülerin bekam im August
2021 den biontech Impfstoff ohne
Sauerstoffgerät kann sie ihren Alltag
nicht mehr bewältigen
also täglich zwei bis vier Stunden
manchmal auch über Nacht zum Beispiel
bei Klausuren einfach damit das Denken
besser geht
und das ist damit nicht diese crashes
kommen also hauptsächlich Erschöpfung
Luftnot auch teils Herzrasen Herz
drücken
Eileen war sportlich und aktiv bei der
Freiwilligen Feuerwehr als in der Schule
die Impfungen gegen kovid Thema werden
entscheidet sie sich dafür
ich hatte dann halt schon bei meinen
Freunden vorher geguckt ob bei denen
irgendwas war den ging es halt allen gut
und dachte mir dann wird auch schon groß
hoffentlich nichts passieren weil bei
keinem was passiert ist
doch Eileen geht es nach der Impfung
immer schlechter inzwischen muss sie
jeden Tag 15 Tabletten schlucken die
Behandlung hat die Familie mittlerweile
mehrere tausend Euro gekostet Ärzte
bescheinigen Eileen ein Post wachsen
Syndrom aufgetreten direkt im Anschluss
an die Impfung
Hilfe für solche Fälle gibt es bisher
kaum die Uniklinik Marburg ist eine der
wenigen Anlaufstellen
dort treffen wir Jana ruhrländer die
31-Jährige hat Biologie studiert und ist
Mutter von zwei Kindern
im Juli 2021 ließ sie sich gegen Corona
impfen danach zerbröselte ihr Leben
ich konnte dann zwischenzeitlich gar
nichts mehr ich konnte nicht essen ich
bin aufgewacht weil ich keine Luft mehr
bekommen habe und ich habe gedacht okay
wenn ich jetzt wieder einschlafe kann
sein dass ich nicht mehr aufwache das
erste was ich dann gemacht habe als ich
irgendwann wieder so ein bisschen klarer
wurde und so ein bisschen mehr konnte
dann habe ich auf meinem Handy das habe
ich Abschiedsbriefe geschrieben und
meine Familie
der Kardiologe Bernhard Schiefer betreut
2500 Patienten weitere 7000 stehen auf
seiner Warteliste die Ambulanz war
zunächst auf longkowitz spezialisiert
und beschäftigt sich jetzt auch mit
möglichen Impfschäden denn bisher haben
wir weder auf Landesebene noch auf
Bundesebene irgendeine eine Förderung
wieder für Grundlagenforschung noch für
Patientenversorgung erhalten insofern
hoffe ich dass der Bund hier seine
Verantwortung auch
wahrnimmt um diese Patienten diese
jungen Menschen die ja im Arbeitsleben
für uns alle gesteckt haben nicht
einfach so
unkontrolliert sich selber weiter
betreuen lässt
warum leiden junge Menschen wie Jana
ruhrländer an solchen Symptomen Experten
fragen sich inzwischen ob es vielleicht
auch an der Dosierung liegen könnte
bei der Impfung haben nämlich alle von
12 Jahren bis ins hohe Alter die gleiche
Dosis bekommen richtig war das die
älteren sehr gut ansprechen weil die da
tatsächlich durch schwere
Krankheitsverläufe und Todesfälle
besonders betroffen war an und die
Jüngeren das war so nicht ganz so
wichtig die hätten vielleicht auch mit
ein bisschen weniger Impfstoff
funktioniert und tatsächlich ist meiner
Meinung nach jetzt an der Zeit dass man
mal anfängt darüber nachzudenken die
impfprotokolle und auch die im Dosen
sozusagen etwas für bestimmte
Altersgruppen bestimmte Risikogruppen
etwas mehr zu differenzieren
in Deutschland wurde vor allem der
Impfstoff von biontech verimpft mit
einer einheitsdosis von 30 Mikrogramm
wir fragen war das auch für jüngere
Menschen angemessen biontech verweist
auf Studien demnach
haben sich insbesondere mit Blick auf
die Sicherheit und Wirksamkeit der
Impfung 30 Mikrogramm als geeignete
Dosis gezeigt dies wurde von den
zuständigen Behörden bestätigt
das paul Ehrlich Institut zuständig für
die Zulassung der Impfstoffe betont bei
einer reduzierten Dosis können auch die
Wirksamkeit abnehmen dies zu erforschen
erfordere große Studien
genau daran mangele es kritisiert der
Virologe Klaus Stöhr der sich mit
impfprogrammen auskennt
dass man diesen hochdosierten Impfstoff
mit derselben Vehemenz für jüngere Leute
empfohlen hat obwohl das Risikoprofil
eindeutig zeigt dass die jüngere nur
marginal profitieren und auch in höheres
Risiko haben für Komplikation das kann
man sich nicht eigentlich nicht so
erklären warum also immer noch zum in
den äh bei den europäisch zugelassenen
Impfstoff nur eine einzige Dosierung für
alle Altersgruppen im Handel ist das
kann gut verstehen
ja nach ruhrländer hat mit anderen
Patienten eine Selbsthilfegruppe
gegründet sie setzt sich dafür ein dass
die Politik endlich Geld für Forschung
und Therapien bereitstellt im ZDF hatte
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach dazu
vor sechs Wochen ein Versprechen gegeben
mit dem Bundesgesundheitsministerium
werde ich ein Programm auflegen wo wir
also die Folgen von longkow wird und
also das wären dann auch Postfach wäre
damit betroffen wo wir die ist also
untersuchen und auch die Versorgung
verbessern doch wann das Programm kommt
ist noch völlig unklar die Betroffenen
müssen weiter warten
konkrete Hilfen sind das eine
Wissenschaftler fordern außerdem eine
umfassende Aufarbeitung der Pandemie
warum hat der Staat die Überwachung der
Impfnebenwirkungen nicht besser
organisiert warum gibt es keinen kein
impfregister in Deutschland so wie es in
anderen Ländern auch gibt also diese
Analyse ist jetzt offen wer das nicht
macht wird in 30 Jahren spätestens wenn
die nächste Pandemie Gewinne wieder in
die selben Probleme laufen
auch Jana ruhrländer will Antworten
verstehen was mit ihr passiert ist
eineinhalb Jahre nach der Impfung ist
sie immer noch auf die Hilfe ihres
Mannes angewiesen
eine Impfung kann Nebenwirkungen haben
und gerade eine den sondern Notsituation
einfach schnell entwickelt werden musste
das ist nicht das Problem da bin ich
auch habe ich eigentlich keinen Groll
oder sowas aber
dass die Betroffenen dann halt so
alleine gelassen werden gerade in den
letzten Jahren war ja eigentlich
Solidarität in das Wort der jedes
Politiker und jetzt ist es im Grunde
vorbei mit der Solidarität und wir sind
so die kollegialen die man irgendwie
zurücklässt aber jetzt sollte man schon
wenigstens versuchen den Leuten zu
helfen